oh what a beautiful time for everything
to freeze up okay good afternoon
everybody and welcome once again to the
Android developers office hours this is
the emea edition where we are answering
any and all questions android developer
for you know for all of you who are
awake during the middle of the afternoon
in the european time zones I'm Sparky
I'm based in Munich Germany and I'm also
joined by Nick and rich and is that Matt
in London yeah everybody's we're here
and let me ready to to welcome you to a
the post I'll resumption of our
regularly scheduled weekly office hours
so with that let's see who's in the
Hangout and what what did you think of
Google i/o hey honey what did you think
of Google i/o did you see any of it did
but as microphones not turned on so I
think time he'll hey Dad I'm very good
Rick you honey low representing the
silent majority today is going to bring
all these questions to in sign language
I thought it's cool it's it's always a
great event went last year went this
year it's always good to see stuff it's
always a little disappointing for us
European developers to see us only
products but that's that's the way
things go that's the world we live in so
when I've had a lot of fun with the Q
though in the u.s. products like the
jelly bean roll out which is happening
across Europe today us products like the
glass developers kick with resembling
for days so so which is worse is it to
be is it worse to be a European with no
expectation ever of getting these things
or is it worse to be an American
transplanted into Europe knowing that
because of where my account was created
I have access to some of these things
but when i try to actually navigate to
their pages it says this doesn't work
here I think you're in the worst
position Harry thank you
Sparky and his first world problems yeah
so you can do some fun with the Nexus
qrt I'm some of your post on Google+ yep
what did you actually get to do so far
one of my favorite lines in the keynote
when it was described was it except
eminently hackable it's incredibly
hackable you can unlock the bootloader
so once the source code hits the android
open source project you're going to be
able to build your own firmwares do
anything you want with it I've had it
running pretty much most of the major
android apps including the Play Store
Chrome you name it it'll do it it's just
a case of working out a good user
interface to it if you hook up a USB on
the on the go micro USB to a USB host
adapter you can hook up mice keyboards
to it it's it really is what i use
devices that it's going to have a big
story to tell it's just up to everybody
to see how they want to use it and in
some ways I think it's nice that there's
no guidance it's a case of here's a
device do something cool with it they'll
be interesting to see what everyone
comes up with very cool so you're
basically just using adb install is this
like pushed up onto the device so i'm
watching launched on there it is pretty
easy to do some things right absolutely
yeah once you've got adb install to
install the apps you can then switch the
micro USB cable across to the USB
on-the-go one plug a mouse in and you've
got yourself a control method so you can
do i was playing angry birds on it using
the mouse and you can do pretty much
anything you want because the media
api's are the same video api to the same
there's no special features or special
api's for the cue it's just a case of if
it's an android app you can run it on
there as long as you don't rely on
things like multi-touch or a camera so
you have you have any but have you had a
look at the Bill berkrot and see what
and property reports mean do you have
any problems installing apps if they say
they require
touchscreen or anything like this I
haven't looked at the build-up prop the
a lot of the ones that a lot of the
default properties mean you can use a
mouse instead of a touchscreen
multi-touch is the big no-no if anything
needs multi-touch that won't work and of
course things like the camera there's
just no camera in it but a lot of
Android apps letter carrick straight off
the bat it's just about making sure the
experience on a TV screen is is usable
and it's reasonable for the size of
screen I think London of frozen again so
since you mentioned the keynote oh and I
didn't see most of the keynote like
because I was working out in the lobby
but I seen something to playback and and
I think my favorite comment by far is is
when the sky divers were on their way
down and and i think was Sergei said
something like that causes for a hangout
on air yeah that was that was an
extremely cool demo definitely one of
those it's going to go down in history
yeah i think my vocalize soldier said
we've won the internet say hey was that
you want it as a prize and it's being
presented to Sergei next week 11
internet hey wait i always like weeks
ago now like
done built priced it up some
instructions but if anyone's having
trouble building on a Mac I've look at
my Google+ stream I put up how you can
build it on OSX line with the ladies
exco version brilliant thanks to that
that's very kind of you report um and
yeah it's all there all the goodness is
there for anyone to play with so so have
you built it as a as a round that runs
on any of your other devices yet I have
it as a rom running on my galaxy nexus a
custom-built AOSP rom knee high silica
jbq and the guys in his team did a great
job of merging in all the stuff
internally and they always make sure
it's buildable on a device when they
release it so it literally was familiar
case of typing make and a couple of
extra commands and hey presto I got
myself a working rom takes all my love
these Tanith II it's only have loads of
questions this week in the moderator so
unless we have any direct questions from
a hangout to kick off with from Charles
your hyna you're out we'll start looking
through the moderate I was I was gonna
put one out to Matt as I see sitting
there quietly in the background and just
said I wasn't gonna pull out a nice if
chris klem is there a mint basic are
using developer studio second screen in
applications something's yes so I can
just repeat that we had a bit of
feedback on this end sure no worries and
is there are other any recommendations
about implementing the second screen
features of google TV and android
application so should developers be
looking to create separate apps or
should they looking to look to you
second screen as a feature of their app
when their apps also running on a Google
TV device so I think in the moment we're
still kind of going down the roof of
promoting a single APK but I think a lot
of developers are kind of getting to a
point where if the content doesn't
really make sense to be the same on both
they probably will go down the separate
APK rubric I think it does depend on the
app so it's nice to have a single apk
and share code but essentially they're
going to go down to very different
routes even though they're going to be
working with each other then yeah just
go for a multiple multiple apk minutes
it's where make sense I think it
deviates so much from the phone tablet
realm that you've really just got to
think what what's going to make your
life is developed for a little bit
easier cool thanks okay hey guys I just
have one question if you don't mind me
asking quickly sure no problem it's just
to do with the the top developer badge
um you may or may not be able to answer
this but we have a client who has an
apnea and the Play Store and that's very
popular it's got about two and a half
million also downloads and they were
sort of wondering how and they could
have in this top developer badge if
there was any formal procedure or was it
just purely a case of you guys at the
developer relations team pic developers
it occasionally so it's not down to us
at all at the developer relations team
if you have a look through a down in
Ian's video from IO you can see where
the selections are made they made deep
in an underground lair laid underneath
Mattingly by the editorial team
occasionally we do recommend developers
for them to review but for the most part
are they're scouring the Play Store
themselves looking for for people who
look like that and the top developer
badge it says 250 the pipeline as well
as the same similar criterias featuring
you know we have people looking out
across the markets of good apps watching
the trending list and so on as well as
you know purpose developer relations
awake them directly and so that feeds
into a pipeline for the featuring is
generally those kind of apps which get
narrowed down to apps which you know we
might want to make up such choice or you
know a developer who's got a great track
record of making complaint you know high
quality applications which might get the
top developer know so it's kind of the
same kind of pipeline really sink on
process who's what's the app I'm an
interesting oh it's this guy's going
around select the other flight tracking
me yep when what you guys said it sounds
like it would need multiple apps from a
developer rather than just one is that
the right way to think it's that yeah
you send a better chance if you've got
multiple i rated lots of install
about that you are going to get
developers who do get the bad with one
application I think if you look through
some of the big names out there you'll
see if they have the top developer bad
we do use it to signify at times that
it's a trusted develop as well as a top
of that said there's nothing that we
Skyscanner could do to to sort of put
themselves out there is that as looking
to have the top developer badge I guess
they just have done that's not the first
day camp fair enough there's no formal
process or submission process for
anything like that man okay great well
thanks for that this is a this is as
close to get okay let's head off to the
moderator then we've got a lot to get
through in the next forty nine minutes
Jonah take over Sparky well so if
someone just mentioned there's a
feedback a three second audio feedback
or any of the other people in the
Hangout hearing that I had it briefly
when I was asking my question when you
guys asked me to repeat it but I've not
heard it since then anyone else having
troubles with the audio I just move our
speakers and microphone further apart
this may be the last of the hangouts
that we do from this room we're hoping
to shift to a hangout studio very
shortly either next week or soon after
so the quality of the Hangout should
improve no end that's just the quality
of the video not the quality of the
content obviously there's no improving
perfection smokey then Joe and I have a
look at the moderator yeah so I don't
know what sir I don't know swung on you
you guys don't seem to be having audio
feedback anymore but I didn't know it's
about you keep your garden decking I'm
getting no parking nope Oh
okay just check which open windows it's
like if you've got the YouTube window
open as well we were getting some issues
before hey which caused us to drop out
Don Luis turn around hey Doran is not
good to see you there in the Hangout
thanks for coming along you have any
questions for us today yeah I just
joined them new eyes and started by
listen more and I don't you haven't come
in with a killer android technical
question for us no no I'm i just think
standard mugen there hengoed no it's my
it's my first experience so whoa the
google hangout yeah yeah well this one's
alive you should know that this is live
on air on youtube as well we should
probably mention that we usually do a
disclaimer at the start of each of these
so this is a hangout on air it's live on
YouTube for anyone to watch and also
during the Hangout we won't make any
announcement about road maps or product
releases superbly so i think sparky's
back with us again now i am back with
you and yes you were exactly right it
was it was the YouTube window I didn't
even realize it was up because I was
hidden behind my hangout window I'm so
much better yeah let's let's see if I
can Hannah moderator with just a sec I
had to I had to close the dead that
combined omnibus window so now I'm just
bringing up the bear moderator right
okay I linked as well and it's also with
me so did you toss haha I operated
question says VLC for Android developer
here from Paris France allo Bonjour do
you plan to support the distribution of
multiple apk architecture based for a
single application says we don't want to
have just a generic 20 meg APK out of
which you pick only one architecture so
this is this is a surprisingly popular
request I think given that there's
there's like hardly any devices out
there that aren't arm-based but you know
of course anything that's that just runs
in dalvik doesn't need to select based
on architecture it's really so it's
really only for apks that have a native
component
and I don't think we've announced
anything on the arm in that regard so
you know going back to a little scene I
think we got some questions in the
moderator which we might have tackled
last week with this being one of them
that yeah we get to see bet that you
want to switch on avi for multi apk and
it's on the roadmap just don't know when
but thank you for the feedback will feed
that through to the developer club
citing one so let's see next one my
widgets stop interacting with my
application one of the buttons is really
simple it has a pending intent to start
the applications main activity what
could stop a pending intent from working
and basically how can you get you know
some sort of interest by inspection or
you know debugging insight on pending in
tents he says can you get log a log
kehte info I would presume that means or
anything else I guess my first question
is you know are you are you doing
anything to say refreshing the pending
intent when say either when it fires
like if you click the button up fires
dare you refreshing it with code or if
you're leaving your activity and
community if you're doing anything that
restarts your your app or activity are
you refreshing your pending intent at
any time and you guys have anything to
to offer on that yeah I mentioned we had
this one last week as well we're gonna
have to ditch down to I think the first
one that we didn't answer was the blood
mask filter question because we don't
have your access to the moderator we
didn't take them off the other thing we
did say last week as if you are
debugging your application and you keep
wishing you variants of it to the
handset from your development
environment then you have to rehab the
widget each time as the widget will
become this associated from the
application but other than that in a
production environment it shouldn't be
happening depending in temperature
remain associated the application at a
long couple be fine do do you know of
anything that would like any particular
events that caused a pending intent to
get dropped or obsoleted or something
okay
lies if the intent the pending intent
taking place not being received by the
application there should be a message in
a cat which says that the intense been
fired even if the applications not
received it yeah okay i justed mind a
little jelly bean stature in the
background for the jelly beans oh
alright so let's move on then we've got
a couple more just slightly further down
did you answer for the blow mask filter
questions buggy further which one blur
mask filter ah not yet I only I reported
it as I found it as a bug this afternoon
and of course the mountain view guys
haven't come online yet so they haven't
seen it excellent that's the kind of
power you have when you find a question
inside the office hours so the question
was Android blur mask filter has no
effect on canvas top drawer oval or for
any other shape while the texas blood on
404 apparently in father's bug net also
my comment there is is out of date I
took the information that he posted to
stack overflow and I made an app that
uses his code so uh that's it yeah so I
attached that to my bug so that the guys
on the Android team should have more
excuse to say all we couldn't reproduce
it here sorry that is that is not a I'm
fussy under the nine that is my book
I've been actually tinkering with it for
over over a week and I just couldn't
figure out what was wrong wrong and some
other guy has posted it worked perfectly
and gingerbread but i'm not sure if
gingerbread has hardware acceleration or
does it no that's why i worked on hot
ginger break yet mmm thank you yeah so
on ice cream sandwich or honey comment
above you can turn off hardware
acceleration for that components if you
want to make sure that it is the
hardware acceleration it's possible that
it is and then some of the hardware
acceleration issues were fixed again in
jelly bean so you may just need to set
it off for honeycomb Ice Cream Sandwich
if you find it is a great oration
reloading and also note on that if you
set your target API of 15 that ice cream
sandwich then you automatically turn on
hardware acceleration so you might not
realize you turned it on oh well I it
wasn't intended to be because it's quite
a it's a heavy application and just come
gets a lot of floats and everything so
yeah so definitely have a play with a
harbour acceleration yeah alejandro
acceleration is not gonna help with
computational stuff it's just gonna help
by plan right those kind of things you
might wanna look at render screw cute
yeah okay sure okay yeah the next
question in the moderator says the
Spotify app and other music apps have
added cover art images and playback
controls on the lock screen can you
point me to the api's on blackboard
tutorial to implement this myself
Sparky's posted a step including which I
hadn't clicked through to but the answer
is remote control flight yeah basically
the the there's some information out
there that was actually provided by the
guy who who publishes is it called
widget unlocker or widget locker this
isn't yeah this is not there this is
talking about the official remote
control client so this as I've Ice Cream
Sandwich there's this is what Spotify
and the built-in music app and uh
perhaps like tune in radio news there's
an official way on the Android let's
stop lock screen to to post the album
art and images and so on and then msdict
and have the playback controls so you
need to look at the Android media remote
control client that's the class learning
track with to do that goody I don't know
if there is a sample code app for that
yet do you know Sparky is it been added
to the random music playback app I have
no haven't taken a look at it okay I'm
not sure that will be but if you take a
look at the remote control client Airbus
and you can come back to us here if you
have any follow-up questions on that
there's a bit of sample code actually in
the API dot to remote
no control client class so hopefully
they'll be enough to get them going yeah
okay to get an efficient sure I'm just
looking through the comments on the
Google duster there's quite a few
comments about how do you start up as a
brand new Android developer and how do
you install the tool chain apparently it
may the documentation may have got out
of sync with the latest Android
developer tools if we didn't notice this
we were doing code labs that Google i/o
this here and the first part of the
total app is to import the project to
twerk it and we send the code lab at the
same time as they're released android
developer tools 20 which changes the
Eclipse import process so absolutely
nobody can complete step 11 of the code
lab but uh the the steps on
developer.android.com / at the start for
installing Eclipse should all the
updates I'll get that checked out if
they're not yeah I would also say that
uh unless unless your app is really
complex you can you can go a long long
ways not importing the project my my
typical approach in Eclipse is is either
to start a project with an external
source rather than importing it or
failing that or possibly in combination
with that I can just create a just
create a basic project with the hello
world app and then copy the source the
res folder the source and rest folders
and the androidmanifest.xml into the new
project and just use those on and just
go from there huh sneaky Oh yeast edgy
yeah still application IntelliJ
personally yeah I I've been I've been an
eclipse user for a long long time and
I've always been pretty suspicious of
any import Wizards related to eclipse
which is why I kind of learned early to
to just copy files into a template out
and go from there
alright want to hit up the next question
like one the unkind fed they've got a
question here it says it's developing
for the latest API level will make my
appt run on all Android devices safe 13
or 12 so I'm going to interpret that and
I think there's two things you can say
when you say developing to the list API
level you need to be bearing in mind
there's the API level you're building
against so you know that's the version
of the SDK or linking at build time and
then there's also the attribute in your
manifest for target API level so those
two things can differ bug you put them
the same so I would say that you always
want to set both of those to build
against and to target to the latest
version of the Android release to
achieve that you know about a new tested
application on and then you can set a
different min SDK and which is the
minimum version of Android which will
run so by setting those two things that
defines the level of the devices that
you app will run on so you need to be
aware when sitting differently basic
signing a contract saying I promise not
to call any newer ap is on any older
releases and it's actually what I gave a
code lab on in Google i/o so if you go
to developers.googl com oh and look in
the code lab section is one about
building backward compatible Android
apps and from there you'll be able to
find my slides and a code lab be able to
work through so hopefully that answers a
question I would just reinforce on that
that your your target API level is not
the maximum that your app will run on
it's simply the maximum whose features
your app already knows about at the time
you write it but any device that has
backwards compatibility is just about
I'll do even on a newer OS will still
run it to spine so so don't be afraid to
put your target SDK as high as you can
and then your min SDK to the lowest
you'll support it's also probably worth
mentioning the the min SDK
it is a filter in market so if you set
it too high some users won't be able to
see if they have an older device so it's
best to check that the features you're
using really do need that API level and
if it can be done with an API level or
two before it's worth dropping min SDK
down right and for certain if you're
looking for you know monetary
justification you know it's really nice
if you can go back to 2.2 or 2.1 get you
know if you want to go really get the
long tail go back to 1.6 but but you can
cover like ninety-five percent of your
possible marketplace like going back to
2.1 was there any update on recommended
methods for using reflection to
optionally degrade features so that you
can support older versions of devices or
older versions of Android as well as
having features in the latest stuff I
prefer to API gate things these days
they used to be a need for reflection in
1.5 and 1.6 those of 2 dot 0 you can
include code inside the class files that
wouldn't be able to run on the system as
long as you don't actually run it well
actually other than is over really
needed for reflection unless you are
manually building against you know
linking against the lower API level and
then trying to invoke you know later
added api's that's the only case i can
think of any imperfection the issue with
the pre 2 point 0 plus low they blow up
one if you try to import classes which
you know on a running on a cupcake
device you can get around that with a
factory pattern which is much nicer than
using reflection my opinion to still get
type safe in tomorrow ok cool ok so
there's some chat going on in the
cheapest post about getting started Matt
storms is M asking for some pointers on
getting started so it sounds like it's
not really going start with androids
getting started with java programming by
sounds of it does anyone have any top
tips of great places to go to bootstrap
your Java development I mean
there's Codecademy have heard good
things about not using myself like that
that's pretty useful for News News
others more than yourselves there's a
million tutorial from gluten balls at
you honey with million people from
groupid so tired new image world there's
a lot to Torres I guess it's the good
ones it started at the hardware honestly
a lot of the a lot of the introductory
Android sample apps and tutorials also
give a pretty good sort of gentle
introduction to java especially the
relevant bits the sea activities and so
on can be quite overwhelming somebody
who doesn't understand object forever
yes that's under step by step see
through going ah you know there's
probably XD Casey yeah that might be a
good place to look
and so on alex is asking when I when I
finally get the new developer console so
excited like like it's headed atop the
brook classic can't really talk about
dates because they'll probably changed
and they'll be wrong and will look silly
so all I can say is like you do the
right thing signing up for the preview
team were working as I can to get out as
soon as possible it's just well done in
signing up the preview as well max out
during the i/o presentation that
announce the previewing because I did
you manage to sign up that's good
because if you try and get to the link
there it just as a thank you we've
already filled our quota puppets so I'm
he will give in because groups of people
to get it looks like when a fun little
let's do happen we've got Trevor who I
might mean us we can hear Trevor so
maybe he would like to say hello and
acid her tell us what's on his mind with
regards to Android development ok strong
silent type stunned him in this island
ah anchor Johnny in the clair thank you
I holidays in Sydney so it's what ten
o'clock there yeah he's got young baby
doses probably at all hours making an
excellent point about that backward
compatibility chat we're having earlier
saying that lint helps you out so yeah
very very much so I think one of the
reasons people used to you know and
change the level of Android they're
building against just to make sure they
weren't invoking any new api's would you
know is now kind of obsoleted by that
you can use lint to do some static
analysis of your code and it will give
you this new API warning if you're
trying to invoke an API those introduced
later than the whatever you set as your
Minister Nidan API up so that's a really
good point it really helps and it's used
extensively in a code lab I mentioned
which which is linked to what is you
still wider than the old / that for
example to pop up lights differently and
ice cream sandwich and a milk the
perfect look she said I can you hire you
before
I guess Bigelow's it's mike so you
should still try to run the applications
and older devices we've already include
such complaints it says some things like
the like the wait pop-ups are council
velocity sandwich they're different from
the old one yeah but I use you to see
that the advocacy survive on trust me
hello hello to always test no device
we're just driving this right another
question the moderator now so I'm not
sure how far um we're in the moderator
you guys ran on hang out last week when
I was in here so I don't know which ones
you've covered a night I bit she might
be them yeah one more word all right JB
them yeah so what question says jenny be
notifications with two actions stop and
play pause for stop the notification
list disappears plate was a new news
well not when you post op the
notification this will disappear but
when you press play pause the
notification with the new icon is sent
but the notification list stays open
other two buttons at the bottom yeah so
this isn't I think he's talking about
the new jelly bean education api's it's
free good listening in my big sister
yeah well I know I know the project
he's talking about the open intense
timesheet yeah he's still pushing some
code and basically what he's trying to
do is have stop stop a task but not
remove the notification from the
notification bar but what he's saying is
when ever stops pressed the notification
is removed from the notification bar I
stops the notifications fierce yeah who
seems reserved what it's an ongoing
investigation for a background service
what is yeah what it basically is a time
tracking application and he's trying to
use the stop button to stop the tracking
of time rather than stop the application
itself yes but he's saying the stop
button removes the notification a season
to fill dirt to build it up I down I've
asked him for the source code he's
trying to get that across to me so he
might have it later today in which case
i can update moderator with it yeah
that'd be interesting to look at on the
border you can set auto cancel which I'm
trying to wonder if it is bound to the
service whether also cancel actually you
know remove the notification when the
service itself stops so that'll be my
first thing I'd look at the API change
right towards just before we open
sources they used to be a window flag
you could set to say whether to closely
anticipation or not that comment I don't
I think they've got removed I have to
check but yeah be nice to see the code
this this you know behind this behavior
so I try and get a link up in moderator
is everyone blaming a noon excitation he
likes yeah I'm it's not it's probably
one of the bigger developer facing
changes and jb aiming jb was a lot of
polish and buttering us and you know
smoothing things out and not a ton of
new driver features but the the
notification if you guys are pretty
sweet so if you not looks at those yet I
highly encourage you to take a look
it looks like a good one also help I've
second question yeah yeah yeah we're
stumbling across from other questions
that we said last week there but there
was one I don't hang out last week it
may be the volume keys question yeah you
can get for the volume keys question
that seems to be quite a lot of
backwards and forwards all that he will
take that right so Johan from
netherlands says I'm working an app
where he traps volume up and volume down
and on the acer iconia 7-inch tablet the
buttons seem to be reversed any idea why
um I noticed that the buttons appeared
to be reversed on the on the Nexus 7 as
well and and and also on a on an LG
tablet that I've got and then and then
it just suddenly hit me it's a portrait
device that 7-inch tablet is by default
a portrait device and when you hold it
in portrait then that that lower button
actually is volume down but when you
turn it landscape hitting that button on
the right makes that makes the volume
bar go to the lab so so my thought is
that it's intended to be a landscape
device and that's not remapping the
sense of the buttons when you change the
orientation of the device I think it
should remap the sense of the buttons as
you change orientation but I don't know
that that's mandated by the platform or
anything like that I actually opened up
a I don't remember if it was a bug or a
feature request on jellybean that we
should in fact change the sense of the
buttons as we change the sense of the
device you know that was my answer to
that question I mean um it seems very
strange when you've got that yet high
ceiling state when you dressed up you
press this wedding it was like we're in
vice versa it slightly gear changing
those Audi dual-clutch cars you press
the the right hand puddle and the gear
goes down the left-hand panel the
display on the screen goes the opposite
way
paddles it's very confusing I'm sure
they've changed that in the latest on my
blog you sure we do it now it's going to
be said for this like the expectation
that this bit of the button always been
tons of volume up you know you just
always if you go monitoring or that if
you like it's a stable experience right
now right I know they're hitting that
always tend to volume up we're go
changing that around with the thing in
reversing understand bitchy I don't know
I'm sure there's tons of Jesus studies
and whatnot behind the choice today I'll
leave that to wiser for justice equal
than I just feel like I get motive which
way is up how do you define which way is
up with the tablet whether you have it
one way with the Elder and other way how
do you find what the UP button is and if
you are going to have a consistent
experience one way up will be another
way down so yeah it is just the graphic
on the screen with the other way to the
direction the presses a button it's just
a thing I think there's there's fair
room for argument on both sides because
you I think it is reasonable from a from
a UX perspective to expect that the same
hardware affordance the same hardware
thing has the same result every time and
and that sort of runs contrary to the
pressing the right button makes the
makes the slider go right if you see
what I mean okay maybe we should just
change it so if your landscape the
bullion bars like horizontal and I'll be
way less confusing yeah it's like you're
not touching all the left it's good
right we should have a second set of
what either you're touching here is next
what I know yes so many cases on it
sorry I can't join bait oh yeah that's a
good question yeah I'll watch it later
maybe maybe simply at a preference to
reverse the effect of the volume button
yet
les rfrences yeah yeah you could in
theory during the application by
detecting the orientation of the device
then altering the action in response to
win all your help about what would you
we need to keep it consistent across
every application right so we either
need to think in the platform if it is
an issue or just accept that this is
change changing okay so that it is right
the way that it is hello what are you
actually capturing the volume button for
your hand is it actually for a volume
control or is it something else yeah
it's a volume control but it sits for a
have you save this server so I'm
controlling an external device it's
basically a remote control data app and
I mean implementing show ok can you say
anymore is it for Google TV or Nexus to
anything however but you could say well
indeed I couldn't freezing the volume of
the next cube light my fire you're
forgetting one yet but it was just in
one particular device so our I'll figure
it out yeah good God you'll figure that
did it two options right yeah this is
interesting i'm they don't catch that
new twitter out tweet lanes that came
out the weekend i think it was which is
using the volume keys to kind of step
onto the next tweet in the stream so you
can sit there and they're just like tap
tap tap tap that happen to use the
screen which is kind of interesting
level i prefer if it's smooth gold X at
the moment it jumped which is a bit
jarring I purpose actually use this few
dots crop smooth scroll to i think is
the AP i'd rather use birth pains
interesting I death yeah
yeah that's a moderator I think we may
have completed the moderator oh alright
so I was just having a quick look
through the comments there's some new
ones that just came in I think in the
moderator yeah like oh why the Nexus
devices no SD card slot I'd like to buy
nexus 7 that 16 again very much it's all
about cost adding card slots costs money
adding making cases that can be opened
up costs money I feel you this is how
the police yeah this is better on since
about I show you this a so about a cloud
oh I know I got it wrong oh yes I
antenna case probably that Custer the
messages that have why'd you need um
yeah i'll be using a gig version and i
haven't really been but it stood too
much me i keep a bit of music a couple
of films few games and it's not too big
a deal really I think I ran out what I'm
the opposite yeah I keep running out of
space for me I think I'd love to switch
to the 16 but of course you can just use
the USB adapter and put in a 128 gig
memory stick in the bottom Linda I'm a
little tiny one maybe wrap around the
back behind some kind of adapter
external hard drive but for that for the
price what you filling up an eight gig
tablet with i mean i i've got my entire
music collection on there and and like a
few dozen games and i think i've got six
gigs free enough movie for a voice of
thunder no in fact he's continued to
music tis thats crazy dude you just be
using the cloud or something you're
using the cloud before you show you my
gauges on here James these days kellie
pickler it games to me it's like yeah
you're so trigger that's six hundred
megabytes hello Kyle it's a gigabyte so
come here too i bought the game to the
sale really it's the sales for more than
anything else while we're talking about
games in nexus 7 please please please
can everyone use some kind of sinking
mechanism to seek progress between
closing
because I'm getting annoyed to play
catch up with my progress and play for a
game twice on my phone and tablet
depending on what I have with me so you
mean like the Google Drive API that the
SDK is going to gasps and laughs exactly
about what does this it have you seen
there are t-shirts they have I think
therefore I am on them no you catch
those I the air asked to get me one of
them as a t-shirt I don't have I have it
rich this is scary Oh usually the swag
magnet right glad you magnet whatever
it's fine okay so that any more
questions from inside the Hangout whilst
we figure out what's next on the
moderator I'll refer to one question
from a newcomer who said how long did
the hangouts usually last and re playing
always hosting them at two o'clock in
the afternoon yes the last an hour and
they're always going to be at two
o'clock in the afternoon on Wednesday UK
time that's three park in the afternoon
Central Europe time we had that last
week anions it's very different i was
like with the currently are but is there
any plan a is it a bad time to you but
no one didn't hear anything back
everyone I just seem to say was a fine
time so now we have a new unisex single
place the coordinating all of these on a
hangouts across all of the products the
cron hang out the g+ hangouts the
android hang out this are all of its
other products they don't get green wave
like this and that's at
developers.google.com/live a google
developers live launched just before I
Oh on Ginny 18 and it's our yeah the
single portal finding out all the
details of all these hangouts where you
can post all the questions into those
hangouts and the different time zones
you can watch the hangout in which is it
certainly why we didn't fuse the events
on Canal G&G plus the think we're trying
to use lights that's where all of the
google developers and hang out and
office hours and so on gonna be hosted
so i didn't find a splint to that
present through if the only filtering
the stuff on live so i can only get
android stuff or people can only get
chrome stuff there may not be yet but I
know when we create the event it says
which products it's full
so I'm sure because the developers like
sites only just gone live there's a
whole team's to work with the
functionality for maybe that will get at
it will fit that feed of acting yeah I
can understand why you want to talk to
the rest of that out then we should
elicit it and then open all going to
party mode and post laser focus
ourselves on the Hangout everyone photo
where they are I did run an event for
this hangouts I'll be interesting to see
if there's pictures of hangouts taking
place in browsers or various peoples
desktops did anyone join there were
people he said they were coming and I
think most of those k i'm gonna join us
now and placed her way to talk much else
Oh someone wants to join in the hangar
who's that who do i still get so the
bathroom over here I want to join now
that's interesting it was probably
executor again I'm just trying to add
you into the hangouts alarm bra some
reason it's not actually what have you
done wrong tific is it when signing up
to LZ keep this event all right I taken
the first PO che so hopefully we can see
how it comes out oh please got an
interesting question I think we've got a
new question in the moderator here I'm
going to work on building an Android
image for a new hardware device can't
find any guide on how to customize
system apps like the ones that reference
internal values and such for example
oxygen will and laundry i would say that
your your route there is to download the
source from the android open source
project and build the social system now
the the actual like the google system of
services apps those you can't get from
AOSP but if you're if you're going to go
that route then you enter into a
partnership with Google and and then
maybe the
EK will be made available to you the new
thing that we announced at Google i/o to
help give hardware manufacturers who are
working working on those devices with
the google added services to to get
early access to upcoming features on the
platform ok miles would be worth
mentioning the CTS which is a set of
guess which apps which devices need to
pass in order to be considered Android
compatible so if they are developing a
new device or something it's well worth
getting all the CGS to make sure they're
not doing anything that goes and takes
the device outside of that test suite
and that so the compatibility
definitions where can you find the CTS
out the CTS is part of the android open
source project and you can download it
to part the bundles that come when you
follow the instructions at source
android com it's a bang on and if you
think that the CTS does not require a
certain functionality that that it ought
to then you can propose a new test and
maybe and maybe even write it and and
offer it as a patchy maybe they'll
accept in a deceitful next round ooh do
we have us do we have a frozen screen
you do and it's such a flattering 12
yeah we're totally back again added what
happened that um there's a question come
through the G+ chat from Boyd saying
that he's not a developer but is that
perhaps a sample app with webview
possibilities I'm not going to do to
optimize html5 for Android to work nice
and smoothly yeah there's a few things
first of all writing Android application
that uses of web view is pretty simple
you can just drag away for you under
there and start loading your HTML up you
do still have to use the development
environment whether it's eclipse or
IntelliJ there are some third party to
which you can use it would facilitate
not using the developer environment
certainly recommend anyone over any of
the other ones of those you can just do
a google search for web development on
android and hopefully you'll come across
those products but if you don't want to
write an android app with a webview it's
all pretty simple it gets a little more
complicated when you're looking at
making it super smooth because the
hardware acceleration of the web he was
varied throughout various versions of
android there wasn't really any in froyo
and gingerbread with honeycomb we added
some hardware acceleration to the
webview but some of the functionality of
the webview wasn't Harbor accelerated
and we have an i/o talk and some details
you can look for on the internet about
what is hardware accelerated and what
isn't it improved a bidding ice cream
sandwich but it's improved massively in
jellybean the jellybean webview has good
harbour acceleration on them fixes many
of these issues you would have seen in
the ice cream sandwich entire web views
so the simplest way is not to use other
acceleration at all and you won't get
great performance the best ways to
optimize it for Froyo gingerbread then
honeycomb and ice cream sandwich and
also jenny be on top maybe do I love our
acceleration on jelly bean and none of
the previous ones it's going to be more
consistent from now on those are
slightly distinct story for each of the
platforms before that I don't know if I
would recommend a webview for like
really challenging stuff that needs
acceleration anyway and me I think you
know that a web app is a way to get sort
of a lowest common denominator
application that runs on it as many
pages disparate platforms as possible
but it's never going to be best in class
on any of them sure but it's the guy who
asked the questions a web developer so
it's clearly the easiest roots market
but we would definitely advocate using a
native views of widgets inside EA just
be aware to be aware of the limitations
in or worth you there yet so far I think
when you stack all your layers of that
sector app step abstraction do you think
on top of each other then yeah you gonna
have some limitations and certainly
never found a web app which is as smooth
why for couldn't improve by do
such a thing in native know there was a
talker I owe this year about making
high-performance mobile web apps i'll
stick a link to that in the comments but
I've heard from people who have used the
evil apple iOS version of the facebook
app which is purely a web app that it is
probably one of those dire user
experiences they've ever had so it's a
kind of setting the tone for facebook on
a Apple device come out with something
that's dire there's not a lot you can do
to improve it I mean I'm not saying
there's no call for it mean gmail for
example uses web web views and to render
some of its content and that's one of my
favorite apps of all time so I'm not
saying there's no place for with you but
I'm just saying you're trying to think
really really kind of responsive and
interactive and flashy then you can ago
like run up against the limits of what
it can do then plus you've got user
expectations and stuff the downloading
an app from the app baseball you're
going to be at that point they kind of
expecting negative thank you everyone
see then an embedded web view so you've
got a kind of hours that out as well as
social movement yeah yeah definitely
very valid points from both madonette
text layout in any app is a using a web
newsstand be one of the easiest ways of
doing that especially you're trying to
wrap text around images and do custom
layouts but I still put the challenge
out there to anyone who wants to produce
a web based application for Android a
web app and then hand it over and see if
we can tell whether or not it's a web
app every time you pick one up it to us
it's instantly obvious that it's a
webapp the scrolling is not like and
trying to do bounce back in JavaScript
or the force field inside android and
javascript is there's going to be tricky
trying to make anything that native or
feels tracks the finger like a viewpager
that kind of views it's just tricky in
the web without it being janky and slow
so i'm good luck but i still have hopes
for the people being up to developing
web technology the way android fanboy a
zillion native of the way yeah and make
apps which we can't tell aren't native
but we also we want this if I Jesus yeah
feel free to just make it so I can't
tell
not very good if we've got a bit of time
left I'd like to hear from you hani who
won a hackathon this weekend we have an
interesting hat I was wondering if you
might be able to describe it to us sure
so we want the only thing us of the one
who build it to the category of
peacocking but I guys hear me ok ok so
we want the google TV category of the of
the habit with you youtube and google TV
shows them I think the London sir well
yeah that's all I cannot lagging it ok
right so right so what we built with
realtor basically stole the idea from
the Nexus Q because the Nexus Q stuff
that I come here so these going to build
one for us Europeans so you build a
google TV application which is basically
just a dummy player and so when you fire
up the google TV app it is so to our
code and then we have the phone
application from tablet applications
which you can use to scan the QR code
and tour the party and he's been
everybody who scans the same QR code
size card at the same party and then you
can just search youtube videos and push
them to the common playlist and the
google TV application will just play the
the playlist until it runs out and they
that always puts more more videos so
this is you see when you and you shoot
player API so basically yeah that's a
new player player API so we can actually
embed your videos in the application and
not launch the YouTube player obviously
if the google google cloud messaging to
the message of people don't have to be
in the Wi-Fi so you don't want to have
to give you all the Wi-Fi connection
details to you any random people have to
be in the party and then the venue's be
rebuilt the application 400 a very
regular application with responsive
design of trouble of your iron and gold
your kids is that using the new
templates
no efficacy templates only available
with the earth app / and some ice cream
770 hi again so so we want to put the
older vodka yeah until we have the
compaction bar stuff yeah ice cream
sounds journey well he says he built it
but I haven't seen a link in play store
yet so i found a bit gave the mat so
you're goofy in your face poison I shall
newer your new Lego a slogan isn't it
Nick no Play Store link node happened
thanks I think they did it happen yeah
damn well I think that just about brings
us to a close so unless there's any
burning questions you guys have been
chomping at the bit to ask but haven't
be able to get a word in edgeways then I
think we might draw this session to a
close so if I'm you very much everyone
who joins us live one so if they all
want a fiddle to a bone questions maybe
some hats does they don't have any
burning questions any of the last people
who join didn't want to ask anything i
post the half 2nd half a second ok I'll
quick there might be lag does anyone
have any questions before year before we
wrap up today ok you should've carried
on anyway stay close try to the
interruption service north service road
insurance and yet but I was just saying
thank you for joining us at one on the
live stream watching on youtube later on
hi people in the future and but we will
do this every week so 2 p.m. UK time
every Wednesday see you next time thanks
guys Cheers hi everyone thanks for
coming and thanks for watching on
YouTube